okay so now we can stop talking about
this race thing we got a black president
it's over but gosh you can't not have a
black you can't let you can't let him
miss this opportunity and you can't let
black people miss this opportunity out
of that fear you know I mean and I can
remember you know sort of thinking in
the beginning or actually reading in the
beginning lots of people didn't want him
to run because they thought he might be
killed and so let's not vote for him
because if he does really well but you
can't be ruled by fear like that you
have to take what comes you can't it's a
good thing good thing if he gets to be
President and there might be this
downside there might be people who who
say that you know racism is over but you
have to fight against that you can't you
know miss an opportunity for one
individual to become a figure of history
like that and for all of us to
participate in that out of your fears we
just had that's something we'll deal
with when we cross that bridge when we
come to it but don't say he shouldn't
win because of out of your fears of what
will come next I mean we have some
capacity to control or to work on what
comes next just go step at a time I
think it's the best way to do this but I
understand the sentiment cuz it's
definitely going to be there
chiseling away those subconscious
notions about race education sort of
closing the education gap between black
and white students you know certainly
the financial stuff that's that's going
to affect everybody but that really
would be the big the next room the next
challenge is to try to have a racial
politics that will what will spur people
to sort of to understand that this is
not it's not all over if we have a black
president or even we don't get a black
president that's that's something else
to think about what what happens if he
loses but really we're chipping away at
unconscious racism and also poverty
structural poverty that
disproportionately affects black people
black people aren't the only poor people
in the country but there needs to be
some way of linking I think I mean for
blacks to make common cause with people
or we've always wanted to do that it was
mainly lower-class whites who have not
wanted that but really try to address
economic issues in this country so that
blacks can be raised as other people
raised as well